to love is to suffer
and there can be no love otherwise
pain and suffering are always inevitable
for a large intelligence
and a deep heart
the really great men must i think
have great sadness on earth
it is better to be unhappy
and know the worst
than to be happy in a fool's paradise
the darker the night
the brighter the stars
the deeper the grief
the closer is god
beauty
will save the world
i say let the world go to hell
but i should always have my tea
man only likes to count his troubles
he doesn't calculate his happiness
the soul is healed by being with
children
i love mankind he said
but i find to my amazement that the more
i love mankind as a whole
the less i love man in particular
what is hell
i maintain that it is the suffering of
being unable to love
it takes something more than
intelligence
to act intelligently
the mystery of human existence lies not
just staying alive
but in finding something to live for
people speak sometimes about the
bestial cruelty of man
but that is terribly unjust and
offensive to beasts
no animal could ever be so cruel as a
man
so artfully
so artistically cruel
taking a new step uttering a new word
is what people fear most
much unhappiness has come into the world
because of bewilderment and things left
unsaid
nothing in this world is harder than
speaking the truth
nothing easier than flattery
to love someone
means to see them as god intended them
i can see the sun
but even if i cannot see the sun
i know that it exists
and to know that the sun is there
that is living
it is not the brains that matter most
but that which guides them
the character
the heart
generous qualities
progressive ideas
you can be
sincere and still be stupid
don't let us forget that the causes of
human actions
are usually immeasurably more complex
and varied
than our subsequent explanations of them
i think the devil doesn't exist
but man has created him
he has created him in his own image and
likeness
if you want to be respected by others
the great thing is to respect yourself
only by that
only by self-respect
will you compel others to respect you
this is my last message to you
in sorrow seek happiness
besides
nowadays
almost all capable people are terribly
afraid of being ridiculous
and are miserable because of it
nothing is easier than to denounce the
evildoer
nothing is more difficult
than to understand him
sarcasm
the last refuge of modest and chaste
souled people
when the privacy of their soul
is coarsely and intrusively invaded
love in action is a harsh and dreadful
thing
compared to love and dreams
the cleverest of all in my opinion
is the man who calls himself a fool
at least once a month
if you want to overcome the whole world
overcome yourself
i am alone
i thought
and they are everybody
the man who has a conscience suffers
whilst acknowledging his sin
that is his punishment
grown-up people do not know that a child
can give exceedingly good advice even in
the most difficult case
power is given
only to him who dares to stoop and take
it
one must have the courage to dare
i am a fool with a heart
but no brains
and you are a fool with brains but no
heart
and we're both unhappy
and we both suffer
man has it all in his hands
and it all slips through his fingers
from sheer cowardice
love of man
even in his sin
for that love is a likeness of the
divine love
and is the summit of love on earth
a man who lies to himself
becomes unable to recognize truth
either in himself
or in anyone else
and he ends up losing respect for
himself
and for others
it's life that matters
nothing but life
the process of discovering
the everlasting and perpetual process
not the discovery itself
at all
nothing has ever been more insupportable
for a man and a human society than
freedom
love children especially
for they too are sinless
like the angels
they live to soften and purify our
hearts and
as it were
to guide us